on va essayer de trouver d'abord la
banane alors je vous explique je vous
explique
on va jouer j'aimerais qu'on ait un jeu
sur twitter hashtag #civsocial aussi
vous trouvez la banane j'offre premier
qui trouve la banane j'offre un iphone
ok c'est très simple vous allez poser
une question chacun d'abord si ça trouve
plus vite sur twitter sa part le le
façon même s'ils trouvent en même temps
ou avant voilà après la première ronde
sur les raisons attention question jean
michel aphatie est ce que c'est un
sportif
savez vous avez laissé 3 30 secondes
quand on est ce que vous est pris pour
tiff
oui oui c'est un sportif un est-ce que
vous avez déjà approché cyril hanouna
oui oui vous est ce que vous faites de
tennis n'ont pas joué de football
non est ce que vous faites du basket non
il participe à une émission de
télé-réalité ou autre chose que le sport
fait autre chose que le sport est ce que
vous avez plus de 30 ans oui vous faites
de la natation non h est ce que fait du
basket
j'ai volé ou perdu ses pairs du s'est
perdu et perdu sur twitter et non s'il
vous plaît dans ce lutteur et non et non
il le sait ce qu'est ce qu'il lance sur
twitter nord ils n'ont pas alors avant
de faire deuxième chance est parti c'est
reparti vous êtes à la retraite de sport
à miami est ce que vous considérez comme
hbo oui à des succès d'accord donc vous
êtes vous êtes un thème well et bernal
bah oui est-ce que c'est dans les sports
de combat non attention il vous reste
plus que cinq questions est ce que vous
avez écrit un livre à succès ici aussi
mais ne sais pas il n'est pas connue que
pour ça a amené un téléfilm un film
énormément
mais qui sont à la réunion je vous
donnais un premier indice allez vas-y tu
une star c'est un de nos plus grands
sportifs à à palmarès incroyable
incroyable il
c'est quoi la boxe non un patineur
exactement ça
[Applaudissements]
séguin a beau commencer vraiment fini
bah écoute ça bien je suis debout je
respire je vis et s'est fait pas mal
c'est quoi là il ya des blogs spectacle
qui devait arriver avec l'aco vite on
est comme tout le monde à l'événementiel
et en touche et on est tous dans la
merde c'est tout on travaille pas mais
bon on s'entretient il ya des trucs qui
vont arriver
pas avant 2022 avant 2022 comme normale
comme tout le monde tu as fait tu sais
qu'on t'aime je vais te remercie c'est
fait la différence de reyniès rigoler
[Applaudissements]
parmi eux et tu sais que tu devrais
prendra aussi un peu publié dans ses
rôles avec tout à fait oui pourquoi pas
dans le même sens de l'humour
attention le deuxième le deuxième on le
fera qu'on a tous je vous le dis il est
très facile c'est laurent on essaie de
trouver laurent qui attention c'est
parti
top est ce que votre déguisement un
rapport avec votre carrière
notre oui ah oui à ce qui est ce que
vous avez déjà volé quelque chose alors
c'est pas michel
g
tu es
[Applaudissements]
donc j'ai pas pu vous répondre je suis
désolé m ission c'est comme les mecs
c'était michel michel on a un gros scoop
il ya un truc qui arrive
oui en 2021 oui oui après quoi c'est la
nouvelle version de la chanson en
revanche pour fêter les 20 ans de deux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étrangers attention aux coutumes des
brocolis à l'orgue est connu attention
c'est qui est ce que vous êtes un
artiste est ce que vous êtes un écrivain
high value tour mais c'est vrai les
invasions je le comprends oui alors est
ce que vous avez fait une émission de
télé oui oui vous êtes animateur télé
paddy matters regard des matériaux
novateurs et oui avec vous un homme
oui oui oui j'ai failli détruire est-ce
que vous n'êtes jury de quelque chose
j'ai trouvé non non est ce que vous êtes
fabrice di vizio
attention peinait à trouver qui est ce
que vous faites partie vous avez fait
partie de l'amour est dans le pré
bon ça qui est ce que vous êtes magloire
non j'ai dit non non non non attendez
cuisinier non non non a laissé ce que
chantait un nom est celle où ils avaient
trouvé des tradis indice à lundi ah si
je donne un indice avait trouvé france 2
déjà passe partout mais non est-ce que
vous avez des cheveux blonds blond un
peu dégueulasse comme ça qu'ils sortent
vierges en chalencon
[Applaudissements]
dantesque
bonjour ça va il fait chaud j'adore les
légumes en plus un légume anglais c'est
merveilleux alors c'est pas du tout mais
alors moi je vous dis parce que même moi
je découpe qui ils ont donné juste deux
secondes avant je n'ai pas d'enfant et
pierre jean ah bah merci d'être là mais
je t'en prie c'est l'année de napoléon
je devais venir
napoléon tu va demeurer à sainte-hélène
je me rendais sans parler envie je
viendrai te parler avec je vais napoléon
il ya un candidat tu vois d'à prendre ou
à laisser qui était fan et qui est fan
absolu de napoléon aussi c'est brandon
wood volaille et apprendre à les six
reviendra bien sûr bientôt et père jean
tu leur as nous faire un truc sur la
ville et au monde
la télé te manque la télé me manque mais
comme toi aussi comme comme toutes mes
amis me manquent
on va très bien mais je suis très
optimiste c'est bien sûr et mais
réfugiés blême chose j'ai ma pièce de
théâtre avec olivier lejeune d'une
chance insolente contrat pouvoir un jour
moi sera olivier je l'embrassé je vois
sur le boucher va très bien merci en
tout cas est quatrième alors alors qu'il
va être beaucoup plus dur à trouver
voilà on avait des les gens très connus
ouais là c'est un autre délire alors
attention à vous de trouver ses marques
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu le délai
oui oui est ce que vous êtes de la
famille de cyril hanouna
non non mais la télé n'est pas votre
métier
si les phalempins ces conducteurs
physique je sais c'est qu'ils n'ont plus
jamais ça à 100 plusieurs québécois dans
son budget qui est le directeur de cb
programme directeur de vous dit vincent
pujol vincent pujol on vérifie ouais
c'est lui
[Applaudissements]
je comprends il faut bien comme il faut
parce que là je comme l'âme
a2a dans son prénom je comprends aux
deux micros peau admettre ce qu'elle a
vécu
chouette est déjà je vais vous 3 vous
remercier merci père jean merci michel
mercier
[Applaudissements]